Audio playback using
AVAudioEngine involves setting up
audio player notes with content.
We will also be using
the AVAudioUnitTimePitch class
to make changes to the pitch
of the audio output.
In order to make your audio
playback code a little easier,
we've included the functions you
need in a class extension file that
you can import into pitch perfect.
Class extensions allows us to add code
to the PlaySoundsViewController class,
even though this code
resides in another file.
This is going to provide you with
a black box to play back the audio but
don't worry, you can see all
the code inside a black box.
And I'll cover it, line by line,
a little later in this lesson.
In the PlaySoundsViewController.swift
file add the following instance
variables enum after the IB outlets.
Now, we can bring in
the class extension.
It is a file called
PlaySoundsViewControllerPlusAudio.swift
and you can find it in the resources for
this lesson.
I have it here on this folder and
I'll just drag it into Xcode.
Make sure, Copy Item if needed,
is checked and
that the PitchPerfect
target is also checked.
Click, Finish.
I'm going to walk you through the code
you've just added line by line,
a little later in this lesson.
For now, we can concentrate
on just calling out to it and
having the audio playback.
First, we want to add a call to the
setup audio function in the viewDidLoad
so that the AVAudioEngine
is properly setup.
This is one of the functions that
is included in the extension
you've just added into Pitch Perfect.
Add the line to call set up audio
here in the viewDidLoad function.
Next, let's configure the UI, so
that the stop button is disabled
when this view first appears.
As the app won't be playing any
sound until the user presses
one of the six playback buttons.
In the extension file you just drag in,
there's a convenience function
to reset the buttons to the proper state
when playing or not playing music.
We need to set them to not playing right
before the view first appears on screen.
Now, what function can we use for that?
If you're thinking viewWillAppear,
you're right.
Let's add the viewWillAppear function
to the PlaySoundsViewController.
In viewWillAppear,
add a call to the configure UI function
telling it to set the buttons
to the not playing state.
One step left before Pitch Perfect
can play back the audio and
that is what we're
going to be covering next.